he's got a stand-up special tonight
Webster Bank Arena and he had seven
hours to kill and he's joined us here in
the man cave he brought in some ringers
and it's gonna be a three on three game
against the dance there I didn't I
didn't want this you guys challenged us
I wanted to just hang out out here I
don't know if it was that way you were
aggressively was not aggressively saying
anything Fritzi am I did I did I miss
something in the email I don't think so
but you may have hinted at a why don't
we uh you made it seem like it was a
round-robin tournament like thirty teams
they're gonna be in today I was like
yeah I'll be a part of that and then
always said it's us against you this is
the opposite of the Rucker League
exactly like there's no talent and
there's only one team yeah but I saw the
lot of stuff from yesterday it was at
yesterday's game you guys did that
everybody looked good out there
everybody looked like the you know the
air balls and air ball that will happen
but but it's one of the worst moments in
the history of sports is a shot that
should not have been taken yeah and
that's what happened with Mario he works
in the back and he shot an air ball and
two-a-days put it back in sent it into
overtime and then they were eliminated
in sudden-death this something about
when a camera is going and you're
holding the ball right let me get some
headlines out of the way we spoke with
Megan Rapinoe US soccer star they beat
Spain yesterday 2-1 USA vs. France
coming up on Friday
Yanis wins the MVP luca don chick wins
the Rookie of the Year and the Mets sort
of apologized for their manager and one
of their relievers challenging hey why
don't they just have a blanket apology
have you followed this story you're a
Mets fan no I am Yankees oh that's right
but now you are what do you mean now
until no I I was I liked the Mets when I
was a kid though I was allowed to do
that all of a sudden became you know the
like but you were the mentioned judge I
was always Yankees Jets but I was happy
when the med student okay but in a
normal but New Yorkers yes yes I think
what happened was my father was a
Brooklyn Dodgers fan
and then when they left he said he was
mad at them so he became a Yankees fan
and that's why I did that
and the Mets kind of felt like they were
part of the Brooklyn Dodgers think so
anyways my my I was allowed to like both
but we went with the Yankees first but
like when you're 15 years of age yes are
you thinking about being an athlete or
comedian I thought when I was 12 I was
good at baseball when I was a kid and I
made the all-star team when I was 11
that kind of thing and then I was laying
in bed I was 12
Paulie double-check that I I don't know
if I'm buying it we're gonna call the
local newspaper huh okay shortstop
starting shortstop now batting number 9
Adam Adam Sun of the year no I really I
was fine I was fine I really did that
was pretty good in Little League
I don't know what my batting average was
but I did not maybe it all starts and
all that stuff and we had a great team
and I was laying next to my dad was a
manager in the league too and he he did
he was the best to me around all you
know taught me everything preferential
treatment very no added third don't know
he would go extra hard at me in fact he
would smack grounders to me extra hard
just to show everybody didn't care and I
broke my finger one time and my mother
yelled at him for what's your dad's
funny I was like you Walter Matthau and
uh you know not like that he wasn't
Edna's hammer he wasn't hammered
drinking no no he was a steady great
dude strong dude you know broad brought
the fear but did he get to witness your
success oh yeah he saw a lot of it he
saw a lot of it because every Sandler
movie if you watched your father's at
the beginning of it yes yes well he he
passed away 2003 but and I was already
doing well and he he was happy he got to
see a lot of cool stuff and he I
remember the the thing he thought I did
best I did this benefit for after after
9/11 that Madison Square Garden and I
sang saying yeah i think i think i did
the opera man I did sang a bunch of
stuff and I and had
the audience was with me and I remember
I've got off stage and my phone rang and
my father was on the phone he because
that a baby he was so excited normally
after my Saturday night lives I'd call
him up he go
terrific good job like he didn't that
was it this was the one he's like yeah
baby that was excellent now why did you
shy away from all of these great
characters and singing for such a long
time and then you put out this Netflix
special that was wonderful
where you incorporated all of this thank
you I guess I thought like I did it I
did it a bunch back then and I've known
you a long time and I would say I don't
know how many times Sandman
can you do Happy Hanukkah I mean do the
Hanukkah song yeah forever and you go no
Danny I think I just probably thought I
did it so much back then it was nice to
get away from it and and not throw it on
everybody every five Oh God
it was it was great to do I mean yeah
I'm running around I'm here near you
tonight and and you'll play this tonight
I will not play the Chanukah are you
kidding me the reason why I'm showing
alright I'll do it I'll do it I was
Jewish would you do it no I understand
it though yeah I mean I friends you were
Jewish yeah I did watch the movie murder
mystery yes human Anniston you did a
great job
she was her her performance was a little
more relaxed when you're not around
she's why is that such a weird freedom I
have on the shooter I don't know what
the difference is that I kept saying
it's kind of the same crew and she's
like no no someone's missing but it
feels better this is an odd thing and so
well you introduce me to her as the
sports guy she like you shouldn't have
done that the first time I meet her you
go uh Aniston this is the sports guy she
may she gets me nervous too so I
probably forgot your name so I was the
sports guy and then I think you said the
same thing to Tom Cruise's ex-wife
Caitie nickles okay yeah okay
yeah I was you didn't even introduce me
didn't nicole kidman well yeah she's way
and all she's you know he's an actress
yeah you don't need oh now you made me
so damn nervous and just go with it
because I Kidman is right there and
she's like an actress she's it like real
like this serious and you didn't even
say Nicole this is Dan the sports guy
you couldn't keep your eyes off Keith
Urban so I'm nervous I was nervous I had
Dave Matthews hitting on me
he was fun that time now have you
thought about reaching out to him again
I am on tour right now and he's either a
couple of days ahead of me or a couple
of days behind me and a lot of the
places I'm playing so maybe maybe I bump
into him but yeah i text with him he's
doing good what about putting him in a
movie again well yeah I can do that too
it's it's it's all about timing and the
guide is on the road a lot but I did
watch the movie murder mystery yes and I
and it was it took place in Europe yes
and I kept wondering what role did
somebody get that other was in mind not
and and I and I believe you now say I
thought this was the Jennifer Aniston
thing like Aniston wasn't good at green
like this for me it was and she was more
powerful than you on this movie has a
lot of lot of say and she actually did
take this see she did a lot of this
movie but and and and produced it all
and and and was very very hands-on yeah
but no there was nothing nothing that
made everybody with an accent you know
they were all real these were not these
were people from different countries
yeah there's nothing I could do Danny I
tried to say you're Irish and it didn't
matter
nobody could nobody because nobody it
sounded like this was a little bit of a
scam like hey I can get Aniston on a
movie let's go to Monte Carlo yes let's
go to France let's go to Italy
yes Montreal did you go to Clooney's
house in Italy yes
wait is that that one house not I went
on the lake yeah he's gonna ditch the
rumble unbelievable oh by the way when
we were in Lake Como yeah it's it's
literally that's all anybody says is
you're here George Clooney's name it's
the most anonymous thing
everybody every move I made they were
like you're just talking about George he
is the king of that that establishment
and like it's an amazing place of his
place is unbelievable yes and and I'm
all they're very nice and Jennifer's
tight with those guys yeah and so they
had a dinner and I went over there with
my wife and did you wear what you're
wearing a similar [ __ ] he's a nice guy
it was a it was a hoop there I thought
that we were gonna get are you better
than Clooney you know he's a real edge
it amid player he's a legitimate player
that's a non-denial no no he's a real
like a real guy like you he knows how to
shoot he's the real deal
weights from Ohio you know in Kentucky
no well but he's from Ohio he's like
yeah yeah he did both states yeah he's
right there yeah he's right there I
wouldn't wear now I possibly you could
take him to take him now cuz he's
injured so it was injury I can be okay
if he if he just gets out of like if he
has another motorcycle accident and gets
up from that night playing I guarantee
victory uh we were also wondering this
would you rather have the career of
Julian Edelman yes I heard or Bill Hader
uh he told me yeah I like him no I can't
answer that question but I do love both
those fellas and I did like everybody's
answer all right what about your career
or Tom Brady's career I much rather be
Brady like you guys were saying we all
want to be athletes I do get to go
longer but Brady who knows how long he's
go you've had a pretty good career had a
very good career but yes when I see him
out there on the field staying in the
pocket and and being that manly yeah I
do I do admire then that more than
watching a rerun of anger management I
don't sit honest and then go look at me
there what was so funny
what movie would you actually watch of
my own yeah when's the last time you
because you can't I turn on my TV movie
I gave myself ten minutes of the Zohan
the
the night and and I was happy I was
laughing and then I then I say alright
let me get at Paulie just check right
now on DirecTV and see how many Sandler
movies are on I'm curious because it
would it be weird if you were by
yourself in your house laughing at
myself what are you watching water boy
that's she's she's seen it
she's seen me watch myself and she looks
the other way she's very nice the
children think it's psychotic oh the
worst is if somebody says did you read
that story they mentioned something
about you Bubba and I look it up to read
the story yeah and then I leave it on a
phone and then my kid my kids take my
phone and just use it like it's theirs
there's nothing like public survey
exactly but if it's on my name and they
mock that but you don't read your
reviews now I don't read any I don't
even read the stories I'm just talking
about like but how do you how do you
avoid that I just don't do it I don't
like but if you see like Sandler Aniston
in movie blah blah blah and you just go
no I fail you do it doesn't ever go
right and Paulie wait what do you have
with the movies well just check-in you
weren't in Godfather two were you I now
pronounce you chuck and Larry is on they
see I got one in there when I show up on
the set that day the first thing that
happens when I get there Sandler goes
come on Danny we're gonna go play
basketball that's right yeah we didn't
even shoot my scene
you said we're gonna go and he handed me
gear and I went to shoot hoops their
size 16 yeah on Danny yeah put them both
together it's size 16 there what was the
other one we played with Paul Westphal
son oh yeah man can issue he was a
wonderful player yeah where was it it
was that grown-ups I was grown-ups I
have no idea must admit I can't remember
Bessy I see you met on grown-ups too
right yeah so Pete Bessey's son is a
stand-up comedian I'm friends with every
legends son you are yeah and this guy is
gonna be able to he's going
play hoops against the dance and he's a
ringer he's smooth now was he on the n1
tour
yeah and I'm on stop I told the damage
that this guy's really good he was on
the n1 torn there girl no no no let's
bring him on you know why that's good
because the there are like magic moments
where all of a sudden if I accidentally
block a shot it is it nothing feels
better the rest of the day he does burn
you the entire day you're getting burnt
if you do one thing right you look at
him but do you play in a league know you
have no interest like they have those
celebrity leagues now I did that a
little bit I couldn't I come not good at
down not good when a ref is around
because I get calls we have a ref today
I know I saw oh that's a problem okay
but they had the Garry Shandling used to
have his yes/no refs there we used to
bang bang hard travel double dribble
alive Garry Shandling play or did he
just Harry Rick he wasn't the best guy
out there but he had a good shot and
Will Ferrel had a mid-range jumper I'm
told I never played with him but I'm
told
got a good great shot and I'm told he's
a great basketball player and then a
great actor he's and a funny in
agreement comedian too is a great man
yes I give him that but do you guys if
you get together with let's say Will
Ferrell was here I've hung out we've had
but do you guys try to top each other no
you don't just just talk but he's in
conversation you know I'd be happier
listening to him than me talking but you
know that comedians get competitive yes
and some do some do some can just sit
back I sit back most of my friends just
sit back there's a few guys who go
Farley was the guy who was always
funnier than everyone Farley had to
compete I don't think he was it was a
competition we like just looked at him
and kind of he was always on the green
light he wasn't always on he was just
even when he wasn't on it was something
money go it was very very bananas rock
you know he's chill he says funny stuff
all day long Spade says funny stuff
Schneider it says funny stuff and Spade
says everything under his breath yes
he's the throw away
and rock is always being funny and Kevin
James is always funny when he wants to
be funny
yeah but most of the guys that hang with
that kind of you know we try to make
each other laugh throughout a phone
conversation but I've noticed though
you're very generous in listening to
somebody be funny I can listen to spade
for a long time because I don't think
David realizes I'm there he just keeps
going and going but but if you weren't a
movie star yeah would you be more
unhappy as a stand-up comedian no I
think you're a movie star and your
comedian yeah and and I wonder if your
demeanor like to be a good comedian
don't you have to be a little troubled
and angry and that helps a lot of guys
and and you get to I'm I'm pretty not
sometimes in my own head but I'll tell
you when I first started stand-up and I
wanted my goal was to get in the movies
the whole time and I and when I hear
other stand-ups talk about that they
didn't like that I remember hearing a
couple of great comedians going you know
stay true to stand up and I was always
in my head going I'm looking forward to
getting into the movies and trying and
not having to do this anymore because I
would get so nervous but who are you
following who lays the groundwork for
what you were trying to do Eddie Eddie
Murphy Eddie Murphy yeah I like them
okay III didn't think about doing it
stand-up special because his stand-up
specials with when I was growing up
those with the greatest tonight they
still are when I watch him but I just
want to jump into the movies did you
ever like you used to be pretty blue
yeah I'm still very blue you are yeah
yeah there was a 12 year old kid and we
tell him not to bring their kids to the
shows you know it's out I don't know
where they write it but it's pretty it's
a known thing don't do it rich he's
bringing his son tonight Yemen he's only
yeah he's gonna be senior in high school
he's about to be 17 so I think he came
in and he saw Chris Rock he's Fritzie
son so he's never heard comedy before
you stand up as solid as a rock
no no he's done I know it's over oh you
quit yeah you know he put the pressure
on me to commit to a specific date to do
it again what were we gonna call it the
go away - go away - work that we would
finally get him to go away and fritzy
doesn't want to stand up anymore you
know what fritzy has that a lot of
comedians don't have he seems like a
good gentle person yeah
where he goes on stage and he's a caring
guy in a sensitive guy I'd rather he was
a bad person he's a funny man but most
most comedians are have a thing about
them that is they don't really care that
much
can you write comedy for somebody else
I've given jokes to other guys yes yeah
I've given rock some good ones really
yes I don't remember one I know but he
always tells me over the years what I
gave him and but I don't remember
exactly yeah but you he gives me some
good stuff - yeah all my friends give me
good stuff yeah by the way the movie is
uh it's murder mystery yes and I'm not
in this movie but I'm gonna be in the
next movie you're in you be Halloween
together is that what it's called so far
I don't have a script yet
yeah well you're funny in it but I don't
have a script you're a school principal
I'm a school principal I'm there you
bring me up to talk to the children okay
it doesn't go well is it a meaty role
it's a solid solid solid it says it's a
damn bad how many how many lines I would
say you got maybe 700 well I'm gonna
need a script we're gonna get that to
you and maybe I could have somebody
rehearse lines with me you can dad will
fly Aniston in for this I hope she's
happy uh it's 20 after the hour will
continue with Adam Sandler and we're
back after this for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on Bri
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]